I don't think I'm going to like it and
I'm a little worried that if I do like
it I won't be able to stop hi I'm
d'Artagnan and I'm a fanny-pack expert
this is the classic way to wear one
right in the front maybe off to the side
a little it might take a little while to
get used to wearing a fanny pack but
soon it'll be like your little friend
around the ages of five to eight I
totally Rock fanny packs I don't think
I'm gonna put a lot in my fanny pack
because I like having the feel of my
phone like knowing where everything is
on my body I'm pretty excited to like
have a way of carrying stuff and to be
able to like not be like art is are my
pockets over fold I'm going to a pool
party this weekend and it might get a
little awkward because I'm just gonna be
wearing board shorts and my fanny pack
I'm actually not really concerned about
what other people are gonna say I'm just
concerned that it's like gonna be an
obnoxious thing who knows what I'm gonna
put in there dental floss condoms mace
oh my god this one I think I might have
had a similar one to this you give me
the pink one I'm gonna put my name on
this in case like someone else has a
pink fanny pack you can ride really well
with my social security number honey -
in case I lose it I grew up in the age
of Trapper Keepers and those just look
terrible minimalism I got some pupils in
my little smiley face some jewel eyes I
hope this fanny pack helps me to fall in
love
Ricky and I were just walking into the
office and been sauce I said I didn't
even notice it at first I was just
looking at their eyes and she was like I
notice immediately okay oh they're not
looking down there metallic silver Chris
refuses to put all this stuff in his
fanny pack so now this is the moment
are you happy about this or sad about me
I don't like no and not knowing where my
stuff is
I know you know exactly where your stuff
is this outfit is not designed for a
fanny pack
I look like I'm pregnant
an important part about fanny pack
wearing is that you got to match it with
your outfit but the cool thing about
this fanny pack is it kind of goes with
anything
those paranoid wearing this tiny pack
because people seem to be looking at
I actually found it I find it really
useful what do you have so you know some
emergency sunscreen oh definitely
so today I walked to and from work with
my bright pink mani pack expecting to
get laughed at a lot but actually no one
really said anything and it's been
pretty convenient to have it all day I
had no cons about the baby back I could
not love the fanny pack more you have to
really base what you're going to wear
around the fanny pack I mean I started
out expecting to be really embarrassed
by it so tonight I'm going to a house
party where I'm not going to know
anybody
dressed like this it very quickly grew
on me I had a great experience I did
love explaining it why I learned is that
people just don't like the name of it
the fanny pack that's a terrible name if
it was called like the pack the hip pack
definitely got a few people coming up to
me miss bingley sup my fanny pack I
don't think they really thought I had a
nice fan pack they just thought I was
weird
I single-handedly brought back the fanny
pack I guarantee it
you could put food in there and just
like like a farm and a ball like a truck
and just like eat you out of it